I go down and there's the rebound by
Gerald Green Rockets with the small line
at PJ Tucker Wang tone 6/8 in his third
year for that bastard PJ Tucker with
another grade the winner these are two
of the high scoring teams in the league
from a season ago in the second and
third highest scoring PJ Tucker with the
three it's on the west bank he was very
happy about coming home Corner three is
good by PJ Tucker hard makes his move
kicks it out PJ Tucker and Tucker gets
his first points
[Applause]
PJ Tucker from the corner clipper
shooting 57% from the field good
defensive play by capella
he runs the court now over to PJ Tucker
who sets the seams of the ball
[Music]
[Applause]
PJ Tucker
nice assist turnover for capella
turnover for pain
extra pass of the corner Tucker for
three hard cuts Tucker left open in the
corner the best player in the entire
league this season in the fourth
quarters he's been mr. clutch Tucker he
was mr. clutch right there
another big fourth quarter three for PJ
Tucker is passing here by the office and
he great Tucker puts it home his could
land the Senate report all leading it is
recently his block kept the line this
Tucker Hibbert and it gets contagious so
the Rockets like you say find out that
he is young he's a household name
Georgia tag
[Music]
[Applause]
the other corner of three open in the
corner Tucker that's his spots that's
just easy money right there Rockets foot
space in the corners he'll shoot the
three offensive rebound Clark
all right the kick in the corner to
Tucker
another quarter three for PJ Tucker on
the drive inside compel awareness
here come the Rockets at the other end
they're gonna give us a cappella again
though this time they said TJ give us a
3-1 81 points in the first half I don't
know what that was by Blake Griffin
cappella the kick in the corner wide
open Tucker buries it going on the tape
down the baseline back out the heart
extra pass quarter three all the way and
it's gone for PJ Tucker if the Rockets
are the first 200 gay isolated art open
look right mama this time TJ Tucker we
go to the third three-pointer for the
Rockets
[Music]
there's Paul back into the corner - PJ
Tucker and that's the right corner
that's the one he loved dumps it down
whoa cappella came up short Paul picks
it up shut clock at five
and it's PJ Tucker from the other corner
a player in habits were with the career
both the Gasol brothers are just
spectacular careers in the NBA mark with
the high school here in Memphis when his
brother was claim for the Grizzlies PJ
Tucker knocks down his second three the
gala show if they don't confuse
interchange Barnegat
that's like Sam Cassell right there you
know what I'm saying well yeah you know
yeah actually looks a little bit like
Sam Cassell in the face
- I was thinking that when he was
warming up
3j from the corner he stares down the
fans stop them on the outside now let's
see if the Rockets can score there is
cat it picks it up to James now James
has pj on the wane there he is
puts up the first Bradley Beal got that
last basket where's Tucker all along
sets fires and hits six last night
[Music]
PJ Tucker
[Applause]
Miami's road record is 87 fifth best in
the Lincoln is as good as you know I
mean when you see PJ Tucker knocking
down that's report
it's three of nine whoa we got that
hands right through the prism Jones and
Tucker knocks down a long shot as a guy
who's the gun for hire in the corner PJ
Tucker games for Houston against those
guys
then kind of giving us a rash and he put
a camp I was gonna say brought to you by
desolate but he only shoes 31% from
behind the three-point line PJ Tucker
says don't leave me open you've been
reading those stats lately but I'm still
a 38% three-point shooters in the league
hey that Canadian
[Music]
pretty good Tucker where the nerve
these tide is going
corners in this game yoky gets it down
while the milsat but it's like playing a
bunch of storming dogs
Rockets on a power play Millsap is way
behind
PJ Tucker
the newly revived 634 nerdy in mime
seconds one extra pass PJ Tucker
[Applause]
PJ Tucker with his seven baseline Martin
with a pocket pass out to Tucker for
three
a lot of points here in the first half
see that see the switches you got that
when you switch that still have a foul
to give
rivers gets it out - PJ terrific driving
kick - green open corner tray and it's a
two-point game because we're talking
unlike we've seen in generations
when Tucker hits the corner grave a
much-needed three ball games Harden
we're gonna get screen sit sit down
that's truck response intelligent in the
double-team again and they're gonna let
Tucker paint all that he can and Tucker
is like if you gotta leave me open I'm
going to knock it that practice once
they got home from New Orleans last week
Tucker at the corner three ball good and
Mike D'Antoni is hoping that he can get
PJ Tucker shooting well again PJ Tucker
for free let's see if Steve Kerr calls a
timeout he's sitting there I think he's
letting hey Tucker loves that corner
three and Tucker hits that corner three
his second one was about to expire
sucker for three banks at home they
counted PJ Tucker continues his fabulous
night at often time no question about it
and of course career-high is 35
in the corner PJ Tucker time way three
for the Rockets just under ten points
per game
Tucker straight up top and the hotness
of PJ Tucker from three continues Vince
Martin is ms-21 straight threes Tucker
has hit five in a row tonight the number
17 in India 73 percent shooting by Miami
[Music]
[Applause]
he got mom but did a nice job in
splitting the double-team PJ Tucker with
the three got it and Houston leads by 14
years Borden PJ Tucker nobody takes more
corner threes league wide than that guy
right there
PJ Tucker who knocks down the corner
three Erick born with the floater
Shiki short fight for it capela keeps it
alive Tucker quarter three knocks it
down and looks at the bench anyone would
use Denise to go back and forth of one
another eight straight though for the
math so the Rockets are playing from
behind no more it's tied at 18 very very
low-scoring and to talk about
massive and hemorrhaging points could
look wide open PJ Tucker let this one
fly and he drilled it a lot of good
basketball players from that part of the
world he was having a pretty good year
in Philly PJ Tucker
now is a quarter three-point shooting
spacing Big Sucker trying to get it back
does it play it well fall back out to a
wide-open PJ Tucker this second Tucker
got it
three-point game 50 seconds remaining
another good rebound foot by Farid he
really helps the Rockets defensive
rebounding woes Tucker they leave him
open on the wing because they went into
the corner to pick up Shumpert and PJ
makes him pay way out past the
three-point line good extra pass to a
wide open Tucker in the corner and the
king of the quarter three it's another
one good timeout good play to get him in
the game and get it to see one going to
basket Smitty Middleton is big as Tucker
knocks down the three but typically you
didn't experience does not win at this
level wide open PJ Tucker from harden
seconds to go Shumpert pressured the
back door finds Chris Paul Paul finds a
wide open PJ Tucker in the corner good
if it goes and it does PJ Tucker let's
go up by 16 got it up and plenty of time
pure shot or tonight's game with
injuries
so they've gone deep into their lineup
for starters and PJ Tucker starts it
right off decides to go for a three
instead of a two and that's the Chris
Paul the thing it was a number one pick
last year he had 35 points Friday night
against New Orleans PJ Tucker is really
warming up from the corners seconds left
there's the double team on hardens
quickly took a fella in the corner to
Tucker
how about that that's how you beat a
double team
I need to be a36 but I think that's
gonna be the team before AJ Tucker wide
open by the yard Mitchell and Rubio with
the mates the show Ingalls now over two
from three-point range
to get harden setting up to carry it
goes he's lucky on my referee I call
that travel every single time you got to
watch the traveling video they put out I
see you look good gather two steps
here's another today number two he can
blow you up offensively because you're
not clean the same way as you shouldn't
face a job by Eagles in a smart play by
three small boys in the layout
[Music]
wasn't bad to be a B+ on then turn off
with my Utah the third by the Jazz and a
pull-up three Paul gives it up Tucker
from the corner got it
BJ Tucker who's global team good
recovery by Utah get it is forget about
my shooting facilities
and guess who PJ Tucker once again he's
averaging about two eight points west in
the playoffs of the regular season three
and that's the three you're going to see
throughout this game over there against
the sidelines now on his free judgment
gets it off the katella's shot clock at
two corners six of ten
if you just picked up for Golden State
some third in the corner limpet was
injured new he is honest off the Tucker
but fate cuts for third different Golden
State defender is on the wedding
dancing and kicking it out Tucker's big
Adama been counting the screen time
develop into three kicks it out Tucker
honey
by Clint capela and the hockey assist by
Harden capela who starts hasn't played a
lot of minutes Tucker 403 good and
Tucker has had that as his signature
shot in these playoffs in Durant on
harden hardy outside Tucker finds
himself free for free at crate shot
outside by PJ Tucker
[Music]
back out to Paul Tucker likes that
corner three
[Applause]
Roland state warriors showing their
championship medal here in Game six
Tucker
fires up the three pointer goes down
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content